Sophie and Richard hey fellows season
five of Outlander people have been
waiting they really want the goods you
do you're gonna have to tell me what's
happening this time what's happening
this season
I saw a wedding someone gets married
I saw it war there's a wall is it war
what else fighting those weddings those
love those cake is baby children lots of
children and lots of animals what's a
family loss yeah yeah but there is
there's a huge war brewing and
potentially some minibus wolves
beforehand so yeah there's a lot more
action this season a lot more couples
and relationships the season Roger and
Brianna are a lot more settled in that
relationship
yeah so that's always nice to see
because as you know they argue a lot
they have had their ups and downs yes
yes yeah we apologize it's been a long
drought Lunda yeah but it's here
has this been easy so that doesn't fuel
look that long for us no because we're
just finished filming here we are in a
press for the premiere which is wheeled
because everyone's been waiting well how
long when was season for a year yeah Wow
dusty like that for us yeah they're
gonna be waiting a year and a month even
once yeah hopefully it was worth the
wait
I think it will be yeah your
relationship in season five will it be
more up or will there still be some you
know rollercoaster wait I think it's
Roger and Brianna there's always gonna
be a little bit of a little bit of
rollercoaster but it starts up so that's
nice start them and they are a lot
stronger they communicate better this
season I think they're less hot-headed
with each other they do manage to
actually breathe and talk things out and
I think their relationship is just a lot
more solidified you know with the
reunion at the end of season four we we
do know now that they are going to
hopefully stay together and it just
seems that any any sort of external
circumstances that come at them they
will battle it together now as opposed
to bustling each other I think they're a
team I don't support of each other
I think we just see a different side of
the relationship that we don't really
see last season so it's good we get to
explore what we do is we get to explore
that relationship I think a lot more or
less season we get to see you know why
they love each other so much and why
they are sort of that's determined to be
together not only destined to be
together but it's they simply be
determined to be together because they
go through quite a lot for each other
and have done and I think it's a very
definite look at Roger and breathe our
season that I think the fans will really
enjoy and their parents now too so they
have a new priority so they kind of have
to be slightly less self-centered each
of them and just don't have to get
yourselves does it have to get along
yeah holding them together that's
probably true also your on-screen
parents on the show mmm Sam in
particular stated that they were the
sexiest couple on the show he's been
saying this whole Roger and Brianna with
a hot new couple and apparently Sam's
know those two will always always be the
hot couple we are the young
sleep-deprived parents now so that ship
has sailed
um there are a lot of love scenes in the
show um but how does it evolve from the
beginning till now in season five in the
sense of you know maybe at the beginning
you're using breath mints maybe you
brush your teeth maybe your breath mint
is anytime ever kissing scene he seeks
out tuna or lobster and I'm not joking
but it's just you know sometimes if
there's a kissing scene and sometimes if
there's a sex scene you know I often
that kind of escapes my mind and I go
out say I'll have a coffee and maybe eat
things or a cigarette some occasionally
honestly
please I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry I forgot that we were
having that kiss and I just had a coffee
or I just had half a pound of smoked
salmon face full of mints and just hope
just a wing in at that point you know
what yeah
jimmy has better breath than you Wow
putting that out to all Canada was this
the standard from the beginning or is
this just you know you know there was
never any politeness at all wow that's
not true that's absolutely true
are you going back to the lobster room
yeah yeah I have the utmost
consideration and respect for me to be
fair they're talking about bad food
there is a really nice scene at a
certain event in the first episode where
food is quite inelegantly shoved in your
face it's actually really quite funny
mmm so you look forward to that
she likes Richard doesn't hold back she
likes to feed me on and off camera
[Laughter]
highly entertaining good fans are so
passionate about this show why do you
think they keep coming back every single
season the tune in for this so of
something you always evolved always
develops it's almost new relationships
well in your places often mm-hmm I mean
we've been throwing the world knoweth
well and I always find a fresh setting
with those characters that you love and
thrown into the mix actual historical
events you know we've got the American
level we are the American Revolution is
brewing so there's always there's always
something new there's always something
kind of to keep it Seconal but I think
everyone can get behind and she's so
much fun and I think yeah especially
this season
I always keep saying every episode
almost seems like a different movie
there's just so much happening and it
moves so quickly that every episode has
such sort of meat
and I think with Outlander it's like
when people say what is it about well
it's sci-fi it's also a love story
there's a lot of action this drama it's
just it there's a bit of everything in
there and again yet true historical
event so I just think there's something
in it for everyone and yeah each season
so fresh that I think just keeps going
yeah if you had to time travel into the
past course and take one thing from now
and 2020 with you what would it be and
why would I take to the Past with me
where are we traveling to this it's up
to you
I was gonna sing the electric toothbrush
but then that seems like a pointed
comment and that's not what I meant my
answer and I'm gonna say I don't know I
feel like it need to take Spotify I
don't think I could live without like
what would you have so much music at
your fingertips what would you play on
my how would you stream it fine Spotify
is in an inbuilt speaker I would take
with me
some antibiotics some penicillin was a
long way you could just make your own
penicillin nice to know penicillin
awesome thank you so much like an easy
Oh 50 caliber rifle but I don't think
that's good yeah penicillin
you think fight but can't even play it
can't even yeah you can't yeah that like
maybe I can figure out a way and I pop I
put yep it I need to sound really
materialistic you wouldn't charge it
I just Briana she's an engineer I'll
create electricity
Addison